- (speaking in Mandarin) disappointed,
(speaking in Mandarin) worry about that.
- I heard disappointed and
then I heard some Mandarin.
Hey, everyone, I'm Kelly.
I'm a culinary producer at Tasty.
And today I'm here with
my friend, Jasmine.
Who's gonna teach me
how to make one of her favorite recipes
that she made growing up.
(Jasmine speaking Mandarin)
I don't know what she said.
(upbeat music)
- Don't worry, 'cause
you got three lifelines.
One, you can Google it.
Two, phone a friend, being my brother.
- Oh, okay.
- Who may or may not know the answer.
Three, phone my mother.
Do you know any Mandarin Kelly?
- No, I do not.
- Do you speak any other languages.
- A little Spanish from high school
and I didn't do very well.
- Well I'm sure you'll
do great in Mandarin.
- It should be easy. Right?
- Do you want me to teach you some basics?
- Let's start with the basics.
- Okay. I'll teach you how
to count from one to five.
(speaking in mandarin)
- Is one
- Two
(speaking in mandarin)
- Three.
- A sun is three, three sun three.
I know it three words is sun make it e.
(speaking in mandarin)
- Five
- Five.
(speaking in mandarin)
- Five bobas
- Soo many bobas
- Why did I think of boba.
- how would I feel about that?
(speaking in mandarin)
- To begin I have all the
ingredients here for you, Kelly
- Okay.
- And to avoid saying
yes or no too many times.
I don't want to give everything away.
I'm going to tell you the
ingredients in Mandarin. One time,
the rest is up to you.
Okay?
- Ready?
(speaking in mandarin)
- yo oil. What's up?
Thai basil.
(speaking in mandarin)
salt
- I'm trying to do my best. Keep going.
(speaking in mandarin)
- Chicken.
I remembered two.
- Okay.
So we (speaking in mandarin) for real now,
(speaking in mandarin)
- let's go.
- I speak a lot of chenglish at home.
I might let it slip today.
- Yes, please.
(bell rings)
(speaking in mandarin)
- okay. Chicken
I heard gyro. I got my chicken here.
(speaking in mandarin)
One pound. That was yes.
You nodded? Yes.
One pound. Okay.this is one pound
Is that wrong?
(speaking in mandarin)
Cut.
- Cube, cube.
Oh, okay.
I'm going to cube it.
I don't know what size
(speaking in mandarin)
four pieces.
(laughs)
is (speaking in mandarin) a number ?
(speaking in mandarin)
tiny. Tiny piece.
- Do you have any idea what we're making?
- No.
I know chicken.
- which is ?
(speaking in mandarin)
You look dissapointed.
I know she said cube the chicken,
but I don't know what size.
(speaking in mandarin)
Yeah, I'm going to wash my hands.
Okay,
I think that means, this means
bowl, put chicken in a bowl.
I hope this is right.
(speaking in mandarin)
oil?
soy sauce
(speaking in mandarin)
measure.
That's a fraction,
(speaking in mandarin)
but half of something.
A tablespoon can't hurt,
but that's not a fraction.
Okay. So it has to be one of these
because these are all fractions.
(imitating slurping)
Soup spoon.
(speaking in mandarin)
You told me it was a fraction.
Oh. So half a tablespoon
and a half a teaspoon.
(speaking in mandarin)
Half a tablespoon.
Did you say
(speaking in mandarin)
That's yes.
I was going to put a
quarter cup of soy sauce.
(speaking in mandarin)
One of these, one of these.
I think it's one of these.
(speaking in mandarin)
Garlic.
I would like to do a quarter teaspoon.
(speaking in mandarin)
That's another fraction quarter teaspoon.
Two times. Quarter teaspoon two times.
(speaking in mandarin)
More.
I put half a teaspoon in. More.
Now there's three quarters of teaspoon.
(speaking in mandarin)
More.
That's good.
So that was a teaspoon of garlic.
(speaking in mandarin)
more.
Half a teaspoon. Add
another half a teaspoon.
I noticed the spoon in the
fraction. (speaking in mandarin)
So what else is left.
(speaking in mandarin)
quarter and half.
This is good.
(speaking in mandarin)
Ja Rule?
(both laughs)
(speaking in mandarin)
That feels like half teaspoon.
What you're saying?
(speaking in mandarin)
tablespoon.
It's five, five spice.
(bell ringing)
I'm just going to do one
and a half teaspoons,
which is the same.
(speaking in mandarin)
half a tablespoon.
So now another one half
tablespoon of one of these.
(speaking in mandarin)
Two. white powder. White.
One half tablespoon white pepper.
(speaking in mandarin)
Half.
Teaspoon.
(speaking in mandarin)
That sounded different than tablespoon.
Salt.
(speaking in mandarin)
Mix.
cover it.
(speaking in mandarin)
Ohh chill in the fridge for..
one, One hour,
(speaking in mandarin)
one hour.
Okay.
(speaking in mandarin)
bowl.
No.
(speaking in mandarin)
Cool.
Something with two.
(speaking in mandarin)
I think I need a lifeline.
Can we Google it?
- Google it?
- Yeah.
(speaking in mandarin)
two. I said two.
all I got was two. Two what?
(speaking in mandarin)
Two tablespoons.
Two tablespoons of corn starch.
(speaking in mandarin)
I'm using one eighth cup, which
also equals two tablespoons.
(speaking in mandarin)
two tablespoons,
sweet potato starch.
(speaking in mandarin)
Chicken, bring the chicken back.
(speaking in mandarin) Coat.
this about right.
(speaking in mandarin)
Processing, processing.
oh, fry.
(speaking in mandarin)
saute
are you climbing?
I like to use another
lifeline. Can I call your mom?
- My mom.
(speaking in mandarin)
Hi mom.
This is Kelly.
- Hi.
So I'm going to tell you a word
and she needs it translated.
- Okay?
- Okay.
(speaking in mandarin)
- Okay. You need a deep pan fryer.
- Oh, I was right.
Okay. Deep pan, deep fry.
Deep pan to fry.
- Yes.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Bye mom.
Love you.
- Bye love you.
- So I was right again with my lifeline.
(speaking in mandarin)
I need to commit.
two cups,
(speaking in mandarin)
Three cups,
enough for three inches of oil.
(speaking in mandarin)
All right. So what temperature?
I heard sun. Which is three.
(speaking in mandarin)
Five, oh 350
Also that's like the universal
temperature for frying. So,
all right,
so I'm just going to wait
until this gets to 350 degrees.
All right. We're about 10 degrees away.
Is there anything else I should be doing?
(speaking in mandarin)
Okay.
One more time.
(speaking in mandarin)
I heard Thai that time. I heard Thai.
Yes. Okay.
(speaking in mandarin)
Pick
yeah keep picking
(speaking in mandarin)
hundred.
I'm just going to keep picking
until you told me to stop.
(speaking in mandarin)
That's enough.
Amount.
(speaking in mandarin)
She's mad.
Alright. I like this amount.
(speaking in mandarin)
I don't remember that one,
but let's call your brother last lifeline.
- Hello?
- Hey Alvin.
Okay. So my friend Kelly
here needs some help.
I'm going to tell you
something in Mandarin
and you're just going
to translate it for her.
If you understand what she says.
- Okay.
- You say.
(speaking in mandarin)
- Take one bowl.
(everyone laughs)
- Okay. Thanks Alvin.
Okay.
- bye.
- Thank you. Thank you.
Grab another bowl.
(speaking in mandarin)
Split it up.
Thai basil.
(speaking in mandarin)
Put it away.
Smaller.
(speaking in mandarin)
Split.
what am I splitting?
Besides my brain in half?
Because I don't know.
(speaking in mandarin)
This is another bowl.
too big.
(speaking in mandarin)
I feel like I'm making a sauce.
Two tablespoons plus something.
(speaking in mandarin)
- White, white powder.
You going to put two tablespoons.
(speaking in mandarin)
half teaspoon.
one half teaspoon.
Salt.
(speaking in mandarin)
one half teaspoon.
Five spice, five spice.
(speaking in mandarin)
Okay spicy.
to my liking.
cayenne to my liking.`
(speaking in mandarin)
That means mix, stir.
Yo oil. Alright.
our oil is at 350. Can I fry it?
(speaking in mandarin)
Basil first.
three 30 seconds.
(speaking in mandarin)
this smells so good
So not only am I creating a garnish,
I'm flavoring the oil. Which
will then flavor the chicken.
(speaking in mandarin)
I love it. Okay. But how
long do I cook this ?
(speaking in mandarin)
I didn't count, but it's
probably been like 30 seconds.
(speaking in mandarin)
Oh crunchy
now chicken.
(speaking in mandarin)
(both laughs)
How long.
(speaking in mandarin)
Three to five minutes.
And I'm guessing don't do
all of them at once that.
(speaking in mandarin)
I think that's enough.
I'll just do half, huh?
(speaking in mandarin)
Okay. Wow.
That looks so crunchy
(speaking in mandarin)
because of the sweet potatoes.
- That looks perfect.
- Good, I think these are
ready. They look golden brown.
I'm going to take them out.
(speaking in mandarin)
Mix.
Thai basil. What do I do
in a bowl mix together.
(speaking in mandarin)
okay.
It's seems right now what?
(speaking in mandarin)
Let's check on these , oh.
These look a little
better. Oh, these got dark.
Hmm. Ohm man. Those feel extra crispy.
(speaking in mandarin)
chicken.
in the bowl.
(speaking in mandarin)
My spice mixture.
sprinkle.
(speaking in mandarin)
I'm just gonna sprinkle.
She likes it. See this.
(speaking in mandarin)
Like, I think that's my favorite.
One of the day.
(speaking in mandarin)
shake.
Whoa.
(speaking in mandarin)
All right. It's in the bowl.
I think I know what it is. Am I done?
- Do you want Me to go get
mine? So you'd find out.
- Yes.
- Okay.
BRB.
I have it.
- Wow. That is so pretty.
- Thank you.
This is Taiwanese popcorn chicken.
It's like my favorite street
food. When I go back to Taiwan,
it is the first thing
me and my brothers get.
We always get popcorn chicken and a Boba.
It's the perfect pair.
Like two peas in a pod.
- It Looks delicious. It smells amazing.
- The skewers Yeah.
- I was wondering what these were for.
I thought it was going to
like throw the chicken on.
- I was scared you would do that actually.
- Would You like one.
- Yes please?
- Who should we try first?
- Let's try yours First
because I saw some big chunks
and actually really like big chunks.
- All right grab that chunk.
- Okay.
- I'm going to take out
the crunchiest looking one.
All right.
thats amazing.
The five spice is really worth that.
Mine was good, but I want to try yours.
- Okay.
- [Both] So good
- Honestly, they kind
of, they taste similar.
- They taste the same.
- This is just prettier.
You know what I want to
try is your Thai basil.
- Mm.
- Much crunchier.
Alright, Jasmine,
thank you so much for
teaching me something new.
I had a ton of fun. If
you guys liked it too,
let us know in the comments
below and we'll do it again till
then. We're going to go finish these off.
- [Both] bye
- I'm just so happy we have two bowl.
(upbeat music)